♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU’VE SEEN THE VIDEO
OF THE CENTRAL PARK LADY WHO
WHEN ASKED BY A BIRD WATCHER TO
LEASH HER DOG, CALLED THE COPS
ON HIM.
>> THERE IS AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MAN THREATENING MY LIFE.
>> TELL THEM WHATEVER YOU LIKE.
>> THERE IS AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MAN.
HE IS RECORDING ME AND
THREATENING MYSELF AND MY DOG.
I’M SORRY.
I CAN’T HEAR.
I HAVE BEING THREATENED BY A MAN
MAN!
PLEASE COME IMMEDIATELY!
>> Greg: THAT POOR DOG.
SHE SEEMS FIXATED BY RACE.
IT SOUNDED LIKE SHE WAS USING IT
TO GIN UP A FALSE ALLEGATION.
ALONG WITH HORRIBLY MANHANDLING
HER POOR DOG, SHE BECAME THE
PRIME EXAMPLE OF WHAT PEOPLE
CALL A KAREN, PERSON GOOD TO
COMPLAIN TO THE MANAGER, SOMEONE
WHO MAKES A SCENE ABOUT NOTHING
AND NOT MUCH OF A DOG OWNER.
IT BACKFIRED.
SHE LOST HER JOB AND HER DOG.
IS THERE ANY SATISFACTION TO BE
FOUND?
MAYBE.
HER MISTAKE ISN’T SMALL.
IF IT HADN’T BEEN FILMED, THE
BLACK MAN COULD HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED.
SHE COULD HAVE LIED SOME MORE
AND SHOTS COULD HAVE BEEN FIRED.
INSTEAD THE PHONE SAVED HIM AND
RUINED HER.
IS THIS DAMAGE PROPORTIONAL?
SHE IS A JERK, ODDBALL, MAY BE A
BIGOT.
BUT SHE APOLOGIZED PROFUSELY.
WHY NOT FORGIVE HER?
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT THE
BIRD WATCHER DID.
OF HER APOLOGY, HE SAID "IF IT’S
GENUINE AND IF SHE PLANS ON
KEEPING HER DOG ON A LEASH GOING
FORWARD, THEN WE HAVE NO ISSUES
WITH EACH OTHER."
THAT’S NOT BAD.
IF HE CAN DO IT, SO CAN YOU.
IF YOU DON’T, THEN YOU’RE KIND
OF BEING A KAREN TOO, JUDGMENTAL
PERSON EMBRACING OUTRAGE BECAUSE
IT FEELS GOOD.
DON’T BE A BULLY.
BE THE BIRD WATCHER.
WE HAVE BAD DAYS.
LUCKY FOR US A LOT OF THEM NEVER
GET FILMED.
JESSE, EVERYBODY KNOWS A KAREN.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE EVEN OUR
KARENS.
ARE YOU A KAREN SOMETIMES?
>> Jesse: I’M NOT GOING TO
ANSWER THAT STUPID QUESTION.
I WILL TELL YOU, I’M NOT CRAZY
ABOUT EITHER OF THESE PEOPLE.
NUMBER ONE, THE GUYS A
BIRD WATCHER.
HOW MANY BIRD WATCHERS ARE IN
PRISON RIGHT NOW?
PROBABLY ZERO.
THEY ARE THE MOST PEACEFUL
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
SHE DIDN’T NEED TO DO THAT.
I GUESS SHE SHOULD NEVER PLAYED
THE RACE CARD AND PLAYED 911.
JUST LEASH YOUR DOG AND GET OUT
OF THERE.
BUT HE DIDN’T HAVE TO POSTED ON
THE INTERNET AND RUIN HER LIFE.
APPARENTLY HE WAS TRYING TO LURE
THE DOG WITH SCOOBY SNACKS TO
TEACH HER A LESSON OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE A BEER
SUMMIT AND JUST SHUT UP ABOUT
THIS.
>> Greg: I DISAGREE.
KATIE, I THINK HE DID THE RIGHT
THING.
HE HAD DEPOSED IT.
SHE WAS GOING TO -- SHE COULD
HAVE FRAMED HIM.
ALSO HE KIND OF FORGAVE HER
BECAUSE HE KNOWS HER LIFE IS
GETTING RUINED.
I’VE GOT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT.
>> Katie: WE SHOULD ALL BE
MORE LIKE HIM.
I THINK HER BEHAVIOR WAS
ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
SHE WAS THE ONE WHO WAS BREAKING
THE RULES.
IN GENERAL, I HATE WHEN PEOPLE
WHO BREAK THE RULES AND THEN YOU
SAY SOMETHING TO THEM AND THEN
THEY ACT LIKE YOU ARE THE
PROBLEM.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT SHE DID
HERE.
SHE UPPED THE ANTE BY BEING
RACIST ABOUT IT AND CALLING THE
POLICE, EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS THE
ONE WHO WAS IN THE WRONG.
IT WAS OBVIOUS BECAUSE THERE
WERE SIGNS POSTED EVERYWHERE.
SO IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT SHE’S
FACED CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS BUT
HER BEHAVIOR IN THIS SITUATION
AND AS YOU SAID, SHE COULD’VE
SET A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
HE WASN’T THREATENING HER.
HE WAS SAYING COULD YOU PUT YOUR
DOG ON ON THE LEASH AND FOLLOW T
RULES.
>> Greg: HERE’S THE BIG
QUESTION IN MY MIND.
SHE DID AN AWFUL THING.
SHE HAS LOST HER JOB AND HER DOG
AND HER REPUTATION.
IF SHE’S NOT GIVEN A SECOND
CHANCE AFTER AN APOLOGY, THEN
WHAT CAN SHE DO?
AREN’T WE THERE TO GIVE SECOND
CHANCES?
>> Donna: LOOK.
I THINK MR. COOPER HAS BEEN
QUITE GRACIOUS.
HE REMINDED ME OF THE FOLKS WHO
FORGAVE THE MAN AND A
ORGANIZATION.
YOU CAN FORGIVE.
IT’S WRITTEN.
IT’S SOMETHING WE ALL BELIEVE,
AS MANY OF US WHO ARE CHRISTIAN,
THAT YOU FORGIVE.
HERE IS THE BIGGEST STORY.
WE DO LIVE IN AN EXTRAORDINARY
TIME AND MOMENT.
WHEN SHE CALLED 911 OH, MAYBE WE
SHOULD REMIND HER THAT SO MANY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN
HAVE BEEN MURDERED AND KILLED
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY EXIST.
I HOPE PEOPLE LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THIS THAT WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT IT TWO OR THREE
DAYS FROM NOW AND NO, WE
SHOULDN’T THREATEN HER LIFE AND
NO, SHE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SAY
I’M SORRY AND GET BACK TO WORK
AT SOME POINT.
>> Katie:>> Greg: DANA, HIS NAME
CHRISTIAN.
I BET YOU WERE DISGUSTED BY THE
WAY THE DOG WAS HANDLED.
>> Dana: HERE’S WHAT I WOULD
SAY TO ALL DOG OWNERS, I KNOW
IT’S TEMPTING.
YOU LET YOUR DOG OFF THE LEASH
BECAUSE YOU WANT THEM TO HAVE
SOME FREEDOM.
IF SHE HAD PUT THE DOG ON THE
LEASH, SHE WOULDN’T HAVE BEEN
HOLDING UP BY THE COLLAR.
SHE COULD’VE WALKED AWAY.
SHE WAS STILL EVER JOB AND SHE